wir machen heute frisches Pesto während
wir die Nudeln kochen also in unter 10
Minuten wir fangen indem wir Pinienkerne
rösten dann zupfen wir ein wenig
Basilikum basilikum ist im Glas jetzt
geben wir ordentlich Olivenöl dazu
wirklich jede Menge Olivenöl darauf
basiert das Pesto und wir mixen das
schon mal durch machen wir eine halbe
Zehner Knoblauch ich fange schon mal an
Käse zu reiben dafür werden wir gleich
jede Menge brauchen Parmesan
und ein bisschen percorino es tut aber
auch eins von beiden so Pinienkerne sind
angeröstet die geben wir jetzt
vorsichtig dazu sag das nur ein bisschen
zerstoßen so dass sie noch ein bisschen
stückig sind also heben wir unseren Käse
drunter brauchen wir auf jeden Fall noch
mal jede Menge Öl
7 Minuten 30 jetzt gucke ich wie viel
ich noch aufräumen kann für alles nach
hinten werfen
okay sieht schon wieder viel besser aus
und zehn Minuten vorbei Nudeln
abschütten Pesto drüber und vermengen
also überlegt euch beim nächsten Mal
zweimal ob ihr ein Glas Pesto aufmacht
denn